welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and Marvel Studios Guardians of the
Galaxy vol 3 gets a delightfully
wholesome Prelude story this week with
the Guardians of the Galaxy holiday
special from which Drax and mantis try
to cheer up Peter Quill for missing
Gamora by bringing home the bacon now I
have not seen this special yet as of
this taping and I will be breaking it
down for the channel as soon as I can
but already from the promo footage and
interviews with the cast and crew we are
getting a sense of how important this
story will be to set up Guardians volume
3 coming this may mantis actor popular
Motif teases a huge twist and director
James Gunn has said it's both an
epilogue to phase 4 and a story loaded
with information for the next chapter
saying quote you're gonna learn stuff
that you're gonna need to learn before
volume 3. uh yeah yeah God you know
we're gonna watch it anyway but I've
been looking closely at the trailers in
promo imagery and there is a big secret
staring Us in the face from this footage
with major implications of the story for
Guardians volume 3 so let's break it all
down first there was this featurette
released by Marvel about James Gunn's
conception of this idea it is the very
first thing ever conceived from Marvel
Studios for Disney plus it's a fantastic
story vomited from the brand of a Mad
genius action on the set of volume two
James Gunn said we should do a holiday
special
[Music]
half we thought that would be great yeah
in this group it looks like mantis gets
cashed on Hollywood Boulevard from
tourists in front of the Chinese Theater
for looking like one of those walking
characters or maybe the Mantis like she
might be a celebrity on Earth after
Scotland publicized the events of end
game in his podcast and his tell-all
book the Chinese Theater in the MCU
remember is also the site of that
suicide bomber in Iron Man 3. you'll be
interesting if this special references
it somehow it looks like the Guardians
have gotten the locals to throw an epic
Christmas party and we know James Gunn
brought in the band the old 97s to do
some Christmas music for this we get
this weird match cut of the guardianship
passing through the UNT and hexagonal
Wormhole grid to Kevin Bacon jumping on
a Christmas tree just like Clint Barton
did in Hawkeye last year in 30 Rock
rocket gives a treat to Cosmo the space
dog remember rocket growled at Cosmo in
volume 1 in the collector's vault in
nowhere luckily Cosmos survived the
vault's destruction seen in the
post-credit scene now this dog in the
comic says psionic abilities telepathy
and telekinesis so we'll probably get to
see this dog do some pretty crazy [ __ ]
in this special and I'm excited to see
Cosmo play a bigger role in volume three
Kevin feige said that he thought Gunn's
pitch on the set of volume 2 was a joke
but then Gunn came back and wrote the
script in like three days which brings
us to the next clip
[Music]
the holiday special it's like awesome
this has been a real joyful shoot
because I get to work with a lot of
people I really love
I think audiences are really going to be
excited it's probably going to be played
every year for the rest of our lives
having bacon you're coming with us
that's a Christmas present yeah this
band singer that we see is actually
Murray Hammond of the old 97s and I'm
pretty sure the lyrics that he's singing
is Santa is a furry freak and then later
at the end of the song I don't know what
Christmas is but Christmas Time Is Here
this is all hilarious to me because it
sounds like the Guardians and their
friends don't really know what Christmas
or Santa Claus really are they're just
figuring it out from stories they've
heard from Peter Quill kind of like all
the cultural references that they've
learned from Earth is something that
they've gotten a misconception of in
their own heads kick names kick ass yeah
that's right and actually fun fact Santa
Claus is technically Marvel Cannon along
with Alf I remember Groot established at
his MCU Cannon by reading an elf comic
in the I am Groot series but the group
we see in this series has much thicker
build our man has been lifted he is well
past the scrawny teenage group from
Infinity war and end game now he's
looking more like a fitness bro in his
early 20s now there was one other clip
released by Marvel of the moment mantis
and Drax come up with the idea to kidnap
Kevin Bacon followed by a Moment later a
vacant scene mantis and Drax on the
security camera maybe if we gave Peter a
really wonderful Christmas gift it would
make him happy what kind of present
something special he will never forget
what about someone special
what over the year school has talked
about one person more than any other a
legendary hero who has saved countless
lives we could give him the quilt as a
present
[Music]
yes we're looking for the legendary
Kevin Bacon we're looking for the
legendary Kevin Bacon
tracks your voice is small and mousy I
think maybe he didn't hear you heard
sorry guys
I can't help you now it could be hard to
watch actors and not immediately think
skin and hair just like they do well
with geology you can geology is a
four-time award-winning personalized
skincare company recognizing Men's
Health Esquire and ask men grooming
Awards with over 6 000 5 Star reviews
and they've recently expanded to offer
products for well pretty much whatever
you need like if you need Hair Care use
geology's co-wash it's a specially
formulated cream cleanser that removes
buildup and cleanses the hair without
the big lather or harsh ingredients of
typical shampoo and for the rest of your
shower routine you can use their body
washes they're free of harsh ingredients
smell great and are refillable and for
after the shower protect your skin from
environmental stressors with vitamin C
plus e feralic serum keep your skin
looking young and healthy and then a bit
of the dermatologist tested aluminum
free deodorant that quite honestly
smells great right now for a limited
time geology is hooking our audience up
with an absolutely insane offer if you
use the code new rockstars they will
give you an additional 70 off their
award-winning skincare trial set this
discount stacks on top of their current
sale prices and there's also an
additional bonus offer on one of their
brand new skin hair and body products of
your choice when you add it to your
trial with the holidays right around the
corner geology has you covered check out
their awesome gift sets featuring all of
your favorite geology products to get
started just click the link in the
description take a 30 second diagnostic
quiz and their team of dermatologists
will design a personalized routine just
for you that ships directly to your door
so sweet Romantics and tracks to be the
ones to do this because remember mantis
is an emotional empath so when something
is wrong with one of our friends she
feels the emotions just as strongly as
they do and Drax has always been a
member of the Guardians of the Galaxy
closest to Peter when it comes to love
and dancing partners after having
counseled quill in volume 2 about
dancers and non-dancers so for tracks
Kevin Bacon isn't just a legendary hero
whom Peter Quill is referenced several
times throughout these movies he's
really the star of dance movies like
Footloose he's trying to find Peter a
dancing partner as I was watching all
this footage I realized something about
where the Guardians and all these other
characters are we have seen this Sandy
floor before with its drainage grates
Rusty bulkhead structures catwalks and
specific neon signs dotting the
storefronts this is the same set of
nowhere that we saw in Guardians volume
1 and infinity war and in that episode
what if that would explain why they have
reunited with Cosmo who was last seen
surviving that explosion from the
collector's vault in volume 1. so what
does it mean that the Guardians have
taken up residence on nowhere and that
it's specifically nowhere that they're
decorating with Christmas decorations
why is this so important in volume three
well of course nowhere is the severed
head of a Celestial and Gamora explained
how tenelier Tavon established it as a
mining Colony for bone brain tissue and
spinal fluid we last Saw nowhere in
Avengers Infinity War where thanos's
intrusion LED everyone to Desert this
place and they found Thanos in the
collector's vault in quadrant 3 which we
learned Thanos had already destroyed and
hid that using the reality Stone it
looks like most of that surrounding
quadrant was on fire now we weren't sure
from that scene if the collector had
actually survived or not since the
collector we saw was an illusion from
the reality Stone but in Loki episode 6
the opening shot showed that same yellow
and blue ship in the background behind
the collector in Thanos this is the
collector's ship taking off in space so
I've always assumed from that that the
collector fled nowhere what we are
seeing now in the Guardians holiday
special is a revitalized nowhere seems
like a hub for settlers in the aftermath
of thanos's Conquest Guardians volume 3
is really going to be a tear jerker
Peter Quill is going to be searching for
his long lost Gamora but that one is a
variant from the events of Avengers end
game from 2014 without all those same
memories of Peter Quill meanwhile it's
gonna be a very important story for
Rocket we're going to learn about
Rocket's origin remember nowhere was the
location where rocket had that tearful
monologue where he screamed about not
wanting to be made but I actually think
will might have chosen nowhere as the
likeliest spot Gamora might return
hoping some elseworld dreamwalking
version of Gamora recalls a time that
she and quilled danced together to fool
around and fell in love in the 2014 film
remember we are in the same Cinematic
Universe that defines dreaming as
glimpsing of the life of one's Universal
variant so if the 2014 variant of Gamora
from Avengers endgame dreams at all she
might during those dreams see into her
alternate 616 self's history I don't
know if Peter Quill knows how
dreamwalking works but if you love
someone so much trust me some invisible
hand will guide you to some space where
you might see them again you were being
Guided by the hope that that person is
having the same dreams about you that
you are of them by the way I think
dreamwalking is why MJ has that Deja Vu
with Peter Parker in the donut shop at
the end of Spider-Man no way home win
that MJ dreams she peers into an
alternate universe sub where she is with
Peter so when she runs into Peter in 616
even though her memory has been wiped
she cannot shake this feeling of
familiarity this is part of the reason I
will always have a soft spot for
Multiverse of Madness with lines like I
love you in every Universe because I
just find the concept of dream walking
both hauntingly tragic and hopelessly
romantic what do you think the
significance is that the Guardians
choosing nowhere as their home in volume
three you can follow me on Tick Tock
Instagram and Twitter at avos follow new
rockstars And subscribe to new rockstars
for more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
thank you